show on the road so yesterday we heard
from their valiant about kinds of
reductions that do nothing now this more
you've got two people who can spin doing
nothing out for a whole night a
challenge I'll be coming down like a
like a hammer on repetition deviation
and the other one I pick up in just a
moment this is just for the Brits any
immediately anyway right that's the
tittle first up is jenise I
wisconsin-madison spout holographic
algorithms we've matched it okay so uh
thanks I suppose this is a talk about
nothing so we have to end right there so
they are three frameworks that like to
address the counting problems graph
homomorphism we heard quite a lot from
Professor leslie Goldbergs talk
yesterday constraint satisfactions colin
problems and there has been quite a bit
of progress in the classification
program address each of them a little
bit but then my focus is going to be on
again do nothing reductions so in this
paper graph homomorphism i was defined
and there's the classic reference
standard book and also they proved the
decision dichotomy you have already
heard about this from leslie's 12
but I would like to move directly into
the counting version so I will define
that the in terms of the partition
functions especially those of you who
are also in this program from
statistical physics you will find it
very familiar so you have a matrix and I
like to start already from the complex
field and I'll say a few words about
this sort of my view why this should be
a right view the right field on which we
discussed here if you given a matrix and
then given an input graph you consider
over text assignments and then these are
think of this Q different colors and for
every edge of the input graph they give
you an entry of the matrix and you
multiply them you've already seen
examples of this if you have a
two-by-two matrix that's 0 1 1 1 that's
vertex cover 100 1 110 will be
independent set the zeroes on a diagonal
ones off diagonal be coloring and so on
so these will represent various
combinatorial problems and this quantity
in the 01 case will be 0 1 if it's a
valid solution to the problem and then
sum over will become the number of
solutions right and so they represent
all sorts of interesting problems here
here's a somewhat less obvious problem
it's a 1 1 1-1 okay so think of this as
coming in 0 1 0 1 and this function this
is a binary function sitting on the edge
and it looks at the two vertices on the
video ends and it's 4 00 01 10 then it's
one and if it's 11 then it gives you a
factor minus 1 so if you think about for
a minute you see that i'm talkin about
let's say you focus on the set of
vertices that are assigned one and then
you're only looking for edges that are
between them those only those edges
matter the age is hanging off don't
matter okay they are product together
become
so it becomes a minus 1 to the power
which is a number of edges in the
selected subset that's induced sub graph
being order even that's an issue so in
fact it would be the number of even
induced subgraphs minus the number of
odd induced subgraphs and in this case
it's a little bit like a determinant
where you have this sort of an even or
then you have a difference except here
the permanent is so solvable easily
because the sum of all even though order
is to be or not to be of course every
induced sub graph is one of those so
therefore the total number is 2 to the N
and induce total number of induced
subgraphs and therefore the sum is
easily computable and then if you take
this arithmetic difference you'll find a
number all the induced subgraphs first
so these quantities have some meaning
and this turns out to be something that
can be computed in polynomial time even
though the definition of thing talks
about 2 to the n terms so then you know
the work of diron greenhill got the
balls rolling where they look 401
matrices and define graph homomorphism
for the partition function and the
question becomes for what kind of a it
defines a problem the problem is input g
compute that ok and they have a
dichotomy signal and this has been
extended by bullet off grow to the
non-negative by Goldberg Aaron grow and
surly to the Rio and then to the complex
and I would like to emphasize that a
when it goes from the non negative two
plus or minus or at least cancellation
and finally of course the complex where
cancellations happen is potentially
where interesting computation happens in
some sense and and this is an example I
don't know
this is an example so when there are
some intricate polynomial time
algorithms then the classification
becomes harder because what if you
believe p is not equal to sharpie now
what we are really basically saying is
that even though we don't see any other
algorithms for this problem there is no
and since they are perhaps hidden ones
then this becomes harder task and this
is in fact for example perhaps one of
the difficulties trying to reach the
decision CSP dichotomy then maybe there
are some hidden
okay so now let me define CSP counting
CSP you have a set of constraint
functions so earlier you can think of
that there's a single constraint
function which is binary sitting on the
edge and now I'm having this sort of a
total yeah so let's say we have 2 by 2
matrices right you do not have you
classified which are which oh yeah this
is for every q q can be good but you say
given a whether it's in pure Sharpie can
be decided in polynomial time oh yeah
yeah this this in fact is a much more
explicit than saying it seemed
polynomial time for have you gone
everything really this statement by
saying it's polynomial time is a little
very weak statement of the truth that we
have almost a closed form expression so
I have you a fire yeah that's the whole
point of dichotomy theorem right but of
course you'll immediately see that this
go is not quite reached by the next
dichotomy theorem okay so this is yeah
this is in some sense we sort of
understood what makes 0 so maybe just
say it what it is it's going to be a
direct sum if you properly suitably
order the colors of the coloring of one
to Q and then each of the block will be
either bipartite or not and if it's
bipartite each block will be as
described below and so now i'm talking
about either the block of the bipartite
part of the individual part and they are
then some sort of a rank one
modification of a suitable tensor
product of some Fourier transform
matrices
and then they are actually this is not
quite right there are some quadratic
form requirements on the vertex ease
which have to come up in this
classification so that's roughly it is
okay so if you think about this
particular one and I imagine that say
you know 41 by 41 for your matrix 41 is
a prime okay so and then you can do
tensor products of these guys then you
do some rank one modification that
becomes one block and then you can have
any any number blocks of this one that's
roughly what it is an hour CSP I give
you a set of constraint functions each
one of them has a certain era T so this
function takes five input than that
function the other family takes the
fifteenth input and they come out with a
complex number and the CSP instance
defined by this set of functions so this
is considered constant now 59,000
functions that's a it's a constant and
once this is fixed it defines a CSP
problem which has input of n variables
taking values over some domain and some
finite sequence of instantiations of
these functions so f1 applies to x 1 x 2
x 7 f 1 again applies to x 1 x 1 x 9 and
then f2 applies to x 7 x 9 x 1 and so on
so forth ok and then you think about for
each assignments of the variable you
multiply these constraint functions just
like what we just did earlier and you
sum over all possible assignments so one
way to think about this is like you have
a bipartite graph where variables on
sitting on the one side constraints
sitting on the other and then every
constraint function applies to a set of
a sequence of variables because the
order matter and then you think about
all possible assignments of the
variables for each one of the assignment
you multiply these constraint functions
and then you sum over all the product is
its sum of product computation
okay and then I want to bring to your
attention the really breaks through work
by bullet off and then further by Diane
Richard be and there's a long sequence
of work eventually says that for any
complex value the finite set of
constraint functions of any finite
domain this problem is either in
polynomial time or sharp York that's the
theory but at this point it is still not
known the decided the the which way if I
gave you fifty nine thousand functions
which type it went to is still unknown
to be decidable what is known the
strongest is for the function where they
all take non-negative values but as I
mentioned the non negative ones versus
cancellations do matter and now I like
to sort of a segue into something that
we know a little bit more explicitly
about the dichotomy and then I like to
go to the holographic algorithms for for
this end so for this our focus on the
boolean domain and for the holographic
algorithms and the match gates theory
and so on over general domains and
something you may want to hear the next
talk will be a wonderful lecture by so
tension I'm very much looking forward to
it ok so here let me define some
function classes these are called affine
type you have a constant it's just a
wait you have a indicator function over
an F Phi sub space / 02 and then you
have I to a quadratic form okay so this
is now the quadratic form since it's on
the exponent of I you can take the mod
for but I want the cross terms like x 1
x x-2 to have an even coefficient so
is the definition and it's defined this
way for a reason because this falls into
the dichotomy these are the tractable
one so to speak by the way this one one
one minus one is one of those things
where and I think about this as as a
minus 1 to the x times y 2 variables and
this is even because it's I to the 2x y
so in some sense you may say well I I
don't care about I why do we why do I
talk about I well what I like to argue
in several points of this talk is to say
that in some sense they are the they
capture the essence and you if you
really want to understand this stuff you
sort of are forced to look into that
level okay so here is an example of how
you how you would write down a symmetric
functions of this family and here's
notation if you were at less talk
yesterday you already were introduced by
this so for example this function says
that if the weight of the input the
number of ones coming in is 0 then the
output is 1 and if the the number ones
coming in is one wait 1 then the output
is minus I ok you say all right I don't
care about this I but what about this
then you have to carry I mean you know
plus minus and so it turns out that to
actually understand this you would have
to write it in terms of the complex
tensor power form in some sense it is
here the iden value so this really
shouldn't be any resistance I mean we we
have progressed like 200 years from the
time of God's did you know complex
numbers shouldn't really scarce right
again but but but yeah okay so all right
a product type that's another type where
you made up by unary functions equality
functions this equality functions some
weights on variables and so on so these
are but they are product over this joint
is not necessary strong set of variables
and they are not necessary symmetric in
the end so the function can be a little
a priori may not be recognizable
and in fact that the Fibonacci gates
that less talked about the yesterday's
talk are those which under holographic
reductions are transformable to these
kinds though so here is a slide hoc sinh
always goes little faster than I want ah
so here's a concrete one over the
boolean so they are very concrete now it
says that your function set is either in
fi or product for the CSP of the boolean
do again the class I just defined for
you and and this talk my primary focus
is going to be if you added volumes
holographic algorithms what happens and
in particular it will be about that do
nothing there was this term cartoon
do-nothing Congress or something I think
we wanted some do-nothing this is
greatest us who are supposed to do the
work so do nothing is great so it's do
nothing reduction to the FK t o brady's
so here here's a setting you have what's
called a signature grid you have a graph
basically we'll see an example in a
minute and think about every vertex has
a function sitting on it and then you
think about the edges as as variables
and for every edge assignments you
consider at every vertex what it's
incident edges are and what's this about
the evaluation is and then you take the
value ok so here's an example perfect
matching right and here's a particular
choice of the red ones as one the others
are 0 sitting on every vertex is a
function that says if the number of red
is 1 then I like it that's a perfect
matching right otherwise I don't ok and
so every valid assignment of 0 ones on
the edges is a perfect matching and the
product in this case will give you a
zero one if it's a perfect matchings one
otherwise zero and some is the number
natural yes where is this word coming
from is it a name of a person or is an
abbreviation what is it ah less missed
you right okay so FK T stands for Fisher
castalian temperley this is an algorithm
that can compute the number of perfect
matchings over planar graphs and in fact
can compute that the way to the psalm of
perfect matches of course over non
planar graphs it's a classic experiment
it's a shot and for almost 50 years this
sort of stood as the algorithm that
turns a generally hard Sharpie problem
to be polynomial over planner and then
let's introduce the match gates and
holography reduction this extended the
reach of f katie and what i like to talk
about is what happens if you think about
this as sort of a day at a class level
can you prescribe the exact reach of all
these things what can it do right is the
classification program
so here's a quote from les that the
situation with P and NP is not
dissimilar very British wheel is similar
to that of other unrelated conjectures
and the possibility of accidental and
freak objects cannot be dismissed unless
you systematically investigated and and
in fact there was a paper by him by the
name of accidental algorithms where he
gave this really weird algorithm or at
least appears to be weird that solves a
certain restricted SAT counting problem
over moth seven but not too is actually
known to be np-hard so then then the
question is are there some freak objects
that perhaps solve np-hard problems and
then I don't know what the professor cop
will think about such an eventuality if
this turns out to be or what less will
think about because this is going to
collapse shop he took the other way and
what I like to say is that at least for
the type of problems we have we can
probably classify them subject to the
belief that they are not and they they
are pretty finely delineated so that
there's no fear at this point but let me
get you acquainted with this do-nothing
a technique okay I really think this
bears repeating that people have seen it
die apologize but you know I think it
has to get used to if if you see it
several times so let's think about a
constraint function this is very
concrete I have four variables coming in
and the value is such that the output
would be 3 or 0 or 1 or 0 of 3 if the
input has Hamming weight 0 1 2 3 4 okay
so remember this a perfect matching will
be 0 1 0 0 0 0 okay and here is 30 100
this is the notation for this function
and then how long will be a psalm of
of these assignments or the edges and
product evaluations so what is this
problem well since there are zeros on
the odd wait so the assignments of the
zero ones on the edges better be or even
for every vertex so that every villa
Texas has to be zero or two or four okay
and if it's a 0 of 4 then the output is
3 and if the number of incident edges
assign one there are six possibilities a
sign is to then output is 1 and you want
to multiply all these together and in
sum over all possible such assignments
so that's that's the counting problem
okay before anyone thinks this is an
artificial problem I want you to hold
this thought for a sec okay and let's
think about the do-nothing
transformation so now let's think about
the incidence graph of this graph where
on the one side is a bipartite graph now
the only one side is the set of edges of
the graph on the right side is the set
of vertices of the graph and there is an
a connection between the vertex on edge
if the vertex is incident to the edge
this is called the ink graph vertex edge
incident gram and now it's clear that
the halting problem can be viewed as a
bipartite version where equality's on
the edge is given as a function and the
original function on the right vertex is
sitting there because originally the
edge is supposed to be chosen or not
chosen and now i'm sort of artificially
saying that
so originally there was an edge between
the vertex and then now I made an edge
as a bipartite graph version and
ostensibly I'm allowing 0101 assigning
on the edges but I'm insisting that they
are the same therefore it's really going
back to the same as a sign when it's
just a interpretations however the ones
you set up this way then it allows us to
a holographic transformation on the left
side and right side and other and I'm
going to transform by this and here you
see the eye appears and on the left side
I will transform by the Z on the right
hand side I will transform by the Z
inverse and this will give the same
value in the end and now on the left
hand side you can think about this
equality as a truth table 1 0 0 1 and x
1 0 0 1 a merely thinking
combinatorially all right the index is 0
0 coming in is once the ink texts 11
coming out as one otherwise the outcome
is 0 it's just the truth table written
as 2 to the in this case two variables
and writing as a mere you know like
computer science will do right this is
you know here's a truth table but then I
want you to think now in terms of not
just as in Upper downs as a values as
numbers and you can operate on them with
these complex numbers lie and then once
you do that and this is hocus pocus
later you get this which is a 0 1 1 0 it
transformed into the DC quality which
says that I only allow 01 or 10 right
and this back into our computer science
point of view discrete math there's an
obvious interpretation of being under an
orientation of the age okay so you go
this way you go that way all right now
what about the other side the other side
you just have to trust me this dr dot in
lie to you but it turns out it becomes
the 0 1 0 0 1 okay
so it turns out it's a 0 0 1 0 0
function so the 30 103 has become 0 0 1
0 this goes through the complex and only
through there's it's possible to do this
but now think about what is this 0 0 1 0
0 I'm doing orientation now going back
to the edges forget about this vertex
I'm doing edges and doing orientations
on the edge and the constraint on the
vertex the original vertex is that it
has to be exactly wait 2 so 2 coming in
to coming out right and this is a
eminently natural problem its oil Aryan
orientation problem I want to orient the
edges so that they are exactly two
coming into coming out everywhere and
I'm accounting this so the two numbers
are exactly the same this is the two
nothing transformation and in particular
I don't know if it's artificial not do
nothing exactly do nothing but we get
something it's great violating physics
always but who cares so so the goal is
sort of I don't want to impose some view
of what isn't natural what is not that I
want to classify so this is the setting
now let me bring in this class of what's
called a magic eight signatures so given
a graph a weighted graph you define
what's called a perfect matching
polynomial or quantity summing over all
perfect matchings and for every perfect
matching edge you multiply the edge ok
so this is the quantity and then you
fold this graph escribe is what's called
a signature or you can think of as a
tensor where the index is a subset of
the vertices that are outside of this
graph fragment or i should say this is a
planar graph and then you compute the
perfect matching polynomial on the graph
where you repeat you delete a subset and
so if you have five external vertices
then you have to to the five possible
values coming up as a tensor into to the
five and of course for being perfect
matching there
only at most two to the four nonzero
entries so this class is going to be
called m and so now I can state our main
theorem that has appeared now with to go
is here so for any set of constraint
functions on boolean variables taking
complex values not necessarily symmetric
this CSP problem defined by this set of
functions is exactly falling into these
three categories remember if it weren't
for the planner consideration or
holographic reduction to FK T we only
had two so here says that's either in
polynomial time regardless any input as
a planner or not oh it's a polynomial
time on the planner at once but
generally hard over the general graphs
or it is a plant shop hard ebah over
planar graphs okay so this is the
theorem and furthermore the second
category where in general it's hard but
over planar graphs is solvable in
polynomial time consists of precisely
those problems that are holographically
do nothing reducible to the a cute this
is the theorem so this is like a
symbolically how this plays out notice
that it's not to say that every function
in the set of functions in F that are of
this type is enough there no mixing
allowed here although there are
intersections between these classes but
the criteria is precisely that either
entirely effort in this or entirely F is
in this of course some of them may also
being a but nevertheless everything has
to be in this or and so on okay so
that's the theorem
and questions I should stop freezing
corrupt me anything little kids you say
you have a tripod abhi but then you say
you can have something in two of them oh
if you were not to think about planner
situation then then the class 2 and 3
got merged they're just over general
graph what happens and that they're all
hard so that was a theorem I already
stated earlier that was due to is a
product type the FI type and this is
match gates but this hat says it's a
suitable holographic transformation of
the match gates so the holographic
transformation now even enters not only
as an algorithmic technique not only has
a proof technique but as a part of the
statement a language to state this year
let me may ask something yes please yeah
please this the second point so if it's
a polynomial for planar graphs it is a
and you mentioned often a discus talent
Aaron so then there is this for toroidal
grass or grass or bounded genome yeah
baby would it somehow so it would it
would in fact I i I'm sort of saying his
genus 0 and you could extend this to
bondage genes but they usually go on so
that the genus goes on the exponent time
yes but polynomial for any fixed surface
for this young yeah okay well well I I
think so i have these things have to be
very carefully written down and uh yeah
but no but this theorem does not address
that technically right it is just thinks
about yeah so if it's not planned out
then the you know technically its
ghostly generalizations they carry right
usually right oh yeah definitely
definitely yeah you can definitely and
in fact there are some people who are
very interesting these fixed parameter
complexity and i think that would be a
very nice open direction to explore
well I should mention that the symmetric
versions were already obtained
previously again ninja taisen oh I think
this universality claim should really be
needed with some skepticism because for
example this universality is claimed for
the match gates and suitable
transformations but match gates are
naturally Hollen problems and there's a
paper by Friedman lovas inscriber that
shows that perfect matching is this
partition from the summer / H cannot be
expressed as vertex assignments on there
it's not it's a strange situation where
the universe that comes from this
Holland primitive in some sense but we
have a theorem that says that over over
the Holland framework this is false so
there are in fact additional category to
type problems
and and there that classification is
only for symmetric and so this is
another open problem where if you have
not necessary symmetric functions what
happens apparently for well I think when
the constraint functions do not have to
be symmetric they are much more
challenge
so now for the remaining 10 minutes I'd
like to give you some flavor of this
proof and obviously I would not be able
to give you all of it because it's long
but it's it's available on online now so
you're welcome to look so this is a
transformation that if you are familiar
with the quantum you're very comfortable
with this this is the ultimate
transformation it's in the unit Terry's
orthogonal and this is the formal
definition of this hat so we had this
match skates and we define the set of
matched case signatures and then we
define this holographic transformation
under the ultimate transformation of the
match gates and it is a simple exercise
to show that the CSP is really the
special case of the holland when you're
throwing all the qualities and then when
you do that do nothing transformation
you get hat on both of them so this is
only in verse by the way okay so so now
I bring this in not because it's just
sort of dear to my heart but in fact the
proof of the CSP dichotomy happens in a
big way as the main arena where the
action happens is in the holland side or
at least equal equally
ok so the claim is that it's either this
so this or this will otherwise is hard
right ok so that's the theorem right it
turns out that will also think about
this in terms of the version in in the
Holland side so this is think about this
like a Fourier transform I I have some
problems I for me to easier for me to
handle in the primal sense but then
sometimes it's easier for me to handle
in the primals in the tool ok so I go
over between them but it's it's
interesting that this is like oh you
know without the transformation this is
with but then if you went over then
these will be with and this will be
without but he actually is its own
transformation so it didn't happen no
change so so these all have just the one
hat on it
as I said a ling variant he had on the
other hand is a much more difficult to
handle than P so we would rather handle
everything concerning p on the P side
inside the P hat side okay but on the
other hand em is easier easier to handle
than M hat so we rather handle on the M
side but remember they are on the
opposite side so there's a tension so so
one you know is the one side says come
here and the other side no no no go over
there okay
one necessary condition for match gates
is parody so if if you think about a
match gates that assigns these values
the value has to be either zero on all
hemming weight even entries or zero on
all hanging with all cases and if a
signature constraint function doesn't
satisfy this but this remember was in
the transformational side it was okay if
the transform function of your original
set of functions do not satisfy this
then it could not possibly be falling
into that type although this is all a
bit self-serving you know we don't have
this theorem here this is I'm reasoning
as if all of this is true this is a
funny way of reasoning about this but
perhaps due to the completeness of this
statement that these kind of
self-serving statements are actually
very effective that you know you have
not gone astray because the statement
covers everything so therefore as long
as it looks okay then it's okay if
you're clever enough anyway you will be
able to find
okay so so so therefore it bifurcates at
this point into either you satisfy the
parity or not and if it is satisfy the
parody then we have some lucky situation
where every function that is supposed to
satisfy the if the transformed form has
off parody then the original one
intersecting the parody ones the product
ones are already in F fine this is a I
don't know a deeper reason for this this
is just a fact really understand these
functions to say this okay I'm saying
you give me any function if the
transform think about Fourier transform
satisfies the parody then this function
if it were already in the product type
then is already an fi and so therefore
this possibility in the dual side
already implies this and if I don't have
to worry about this and therefore I only
worry about this which makes me able to
reason only on the 20 side okay because
on a dual side is is the m and this
okay so this is what I said if it fails
sorry so so then there are two cases one
is if satisfied it fails the first case
is if it fails then there's something
that fails then we do a arity reduction
to produce a unary one that fails this
is a function that both have nonzero
entries of a one variable function that
already fails the parity and then quite
a bit of work after this to deal with it
one of the idea is that we would like to
utilize the symmetric ones so once we're
given something that are neither in a or
p because if it were in a or p entirely
then the thing is already in polynomial
time we don't want to prove its Sharpie
heart this is like right okay insane so
we assume that something is not in a
something darling p they may be the same
but may be different and in this case we
would like to construct something that's
symmetric because we have a symmetric
dichotomy so we're going to apply the
symmetric dichotomy on this the
difficulty with this is generally
speaking it's bit hard to construct
planar ones but this case I don't really
care that much because the A&P applies
to non planner so the second case is
that all of the signatures or the
constraints satisfy the parity okay then
of course if this and this and this this
is already in a dual side okay this is
all ready to do sigh then the problem is
in polynomial time
but as I noted that if it already the
duo size satisfy the parody then I have
the lucky case that I can eliminate one
of the cases so then it is talking about
this so this is what I want to prove
this is logically equivalent to the
tripartite condition but in this case
the natural idea is to find a nom fi now
matched case symmetric ones then the
appeal to the dichotomy and this doesn't
work so what we instead do is trying to
get the equality for or the crossover
once you have the crossover you can
appeal to the non-planar that cotton tee
and a crossover is this function which
if you squint closely you'll find that
this is about some equality ok so it's
the first and a third variable are equal
and once you have that then it's like
effectively allowed you to disregard
planarity
so once we have the equality however we
can get this class called that the
planner CSP to these are special cases
of CSP problems where every variable
appears an even number of times and so
once you get in a duo side you get that
the equality for then you get equality's
of all even arity then you get the CSP
too but then it comes as sort of a what
I call the cognitive dissonance so this
guy looks like a CSP but this was on the
dual sided so it was the CSP under the
holographic transformation went into the
holland and then and hocus pocus i got
into a CSP type problem again and then
we are going to apply a CSP tool which
is kind of CSP like dichotomy criteria
on this and this transformation is
specifically to get into like the match
gates side but then these things are not
going to satisfy the match gates and so
it eliminates a lot of things at which
point we have five classes remain and
then you can wheel out for the five and
then you work a little harder you get
the last
should I stop here you can if you if
that's not how many minutes do you think
I had
okay yes so let's sorry go back to the
scrap okay so let's just take a 2 by 2
matrix and breathe ABCD further back but
there you de jamon Y so we have a this
is 2 a 2 matrix so q is too so we have
entries to know let little a little B
little seeds it will d so that would be
if B is not equal to C then there will
be a directed graph version because the
0 1 1 0 is equal now that's a dress so
if you were to have the same it would be
there okay know which values of a b c
and d are you in which category you want
me to enumerate all of them oh it's
infinite so but it should be a nuke is
it an arugula ah so there's another is
there an algebraic conditioning at an a
b c and d oh are you worried about the
sea being sort of a on computable
numbers or something no no I'm not
worried are perfectly at home with
complex numbers so I want algebraic
numbers let me be a so I hand you
algebraic numbers yeah yeah how do you
tell me which which category it said for
this particular case of two by two so i
can i can say that it's you know
something like this this is a bipartite
okay and then you can have a + b + 0 0
that will be a generosity quality we're
gonna have 1 1 or minus 1 where are you
sure p hard these are the peak this is
these are the p yeah yeah
LOL there's the rank 1 also in this
world if the rank is one
ok so it's so in this case is pretty
simple to enumerate
so we have a four-dimensional space two
dimensional subsets gutter in and then
there's isolated points is that what you
break variety yes but I don't know
absolutely not now York understanding or
at least you're indicating your I think
I'm indicating that i don't know is
there for instance a holographic
calculation of a determinant of
determinant i can't ieave are you and he
says the holographic algorithms are the
transformations to get into the
determinant so once you get the
determinants considered that done okay
right the f katie the saffiano girdim is
a determinant so yes but assume that is
there is still let say something in the
term in this simple it or not because if
you have four metrics is variables then
it's hard right then it's not so clear
well if so that the data grant can make
exponential number of times for instance
if the number of variables is no bomb
day but it's a it's a it's a nice simple
language so if if they're so would there
be some way to let's say to calculate
that and locally with something yeah
yeah it's also so can you gimme so I
guess one of the question would be like
can express determinate as a CSP yeah oh
yeah
i don't know i don't think so yeah
nothing
I was going towards the same question so
I wanted just a plain in cabinet general
Braun so where does it get into that
picture well they are not you have to
express as a CSP problems to express
this so I don't know if it can be
expressed as a CSV probably not get the
Hamiltonian circuit for example cannot
be expressed yes we are things they are
not expressible okay I also video
outside of this right right right right
definitely like for example the crush of
tree matrix is not
is what I program is very similar to
chmod I'll or which is growth as well
the local Roble comradeship yeah don't
have anything
it for you you have main theorem and you
have this example because the 2012 did
you say how many example just as
actually in the Holland so this fits
into the holland dichotomy aware in fact
there are a counterexample to this
universality technically it's a Holland
problem so beyond the CSP awesome
ok
ok